hello everyone and welcome to our
macsite sponsored webinar titled
scalable manufacturing and nanovesicle
delivery
of crispr cas9 nuclear nuclear
ribonucleoproteins using a cgmp
compliant cell engineering platform my
name is leslie eschenger and i am a
director of marketing for mac site
i will be your moderator for today's
engaging session
i would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive so we
encourage you to participate by
submitting questions
at any time during the presentation to
do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click on the send button if at any
time you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
please click on the tab found at the top
right of the presentation window
our speaker for today's session will be
peter g
a field application scientist at macsite
for computers for peter's complete
biography
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
without further delay let me turn this
session
over to mr peter g
okay so thank you for the introduction
leslie
and thank you to everyone who's tuning
in for
today's webinar before i
joined max site i was a postdoctoral
research fellow
at the center for ipsl research and
application at kyoto
university in akita holta's laboratory
and there we were working on developing
new technology uh delivery technologies
for the crispr cas9 ribonuclear protein
complex
so today i'm really happy to share the
results of our research
um this was five years in the making it
was recently published in nature
communications
um showing the development of a new uh
crispr cas9 delivery platform
using a gmp compliant cell engineering
platform
so for today's agenda i'll go into the
background about
viral versus extracellular vesicle
delivery
and then uh talk about the development
of our
rnp delivery system that we term
nanomedic
i'll then talk about a few applications
using nanomedic and various
uh cell types some difficult to
transfect
typically and also some in vivo studies
where we show delivery of nanomedicine
vivo
then i would like to go into the
development of nanomedic by
electroporation we found
initially that we could generate
nanomedic at the small scale using lipid
transfection but we found
um that we were having struggles with
with scalable production of nanomedics
so
we we then moved on to nanomedic
production by electroporation and then
scalable production by flow
electroporation
so going into the background of crispr
cast 9 and
its delivery i think most of you may
know but crispr cast 9 is
a powerful genome editing tool to
introduce double-stranded breaks
into the host's dna genome and it
consists of a
a nuclease and a guide rna molecule
that can identify a 20-base pair
complementary sequence
in the genomic dna so the only
difficulty with um
applying crispr cas9 for
uh therapy in in the clinic or or in
difficult to
transfect cells is is there there are
very limited
options for delivery of this system so
adeno associated viruses you can see on
on the right
figure is the most common vector for
delivering
crispr cas9 in vivo and it expresses
cas9 in the guide rna through an
episomal dna vector
the expression can be very long term
actually
years being expressed from this vector
but there are a few disadvantages
so those disadvantages are
an increased risk of an immune response
to
for example the the cat9 protein itself
being expressed
in the um corrected cells or even if you
get
correction of your um your cells
if they express cas9 they could be
eliminated by your immune system
and second uh the fact that you're using
crispr cast 9
to introduce double stranded breaks
sometimes the the viral vector
backbone will be non-specifically
integrated into the host genome so
there is the risk of that and finally
there's a risk of off-target cleavage by
the crispr cas9 nucleus so
if you leave it in the cell for too long
it's
it can cut um similar
site recognition sites that may be off
by up to four base pairs so
ideally you want to deliver crisper cas9
transiently
and support to do its job and then and
then get it out of the cell
um so we we sought to develop a
transient
crispr casting delivery system um that
we hoped for
that we could apply for in-vivo gene
editing
and so to do this we kind of looked at
extracellular vesicles as possible
delivery vehicles so so what are
um extracellular vesicles that all refer
to as ev from now
so they're cell derived membrane
structures
that range in diameter it's pretty
diverse but the ones that i'm referring
to
are 50 to 100 meter nanometers in
diameter
and and they're secreted from cells so
previously
these secreted evs were were thought to
kind of be the garbage trucks themselves
they they carry
excess um cargo
which is unnecessary that's what was
believed before but
actually the cargo that they carry are
bio-active molecules
such as lipids proteins and rna that
have biological function uh it's
involved in immune responses and
intracellular
communication with other cells and
sometimes viruses can use them for viral
pathogenesis
so if you kind of look at the figure on
the right here this is a cell
infected by hiv but some viruses
when they over express their proteins in
cells they can utilize the ev machinery
to package their own proteins
and components into these budding evs so
in a sense you can you can think that if
you over
express a protein of interest in the
cell you can utilize the eevee machine
machinery to deliver your protein of
interest
so you can kind of use these evs as
suitcases
and package what you want into them for
delivery
into other cells so
in this sense you can harness evs for
protein delivery
and evs are can essentially be shells of
self-assembling
viral structural proteins and you can
remove the genomic dna
and uh genomic rna so
just as an example we wanted to look at
lentiviruses as
as kind of a base for this system and
lengthy viruses have
enzyme enzymes such as reverse
transcriptase and protease and integrase
which are involved in various steps of
the virus life cycle to permanently
integrate
uh dna in the target cell however if you
kind of take away these components and
just use the structural
aspects of viral particles such as
an envelope protein for cell targeting
gag which is a structural protein which
helps
kind of the particle formation you can
just use
these two components and we wanted to
package the cas9 protein and the guide
rna into these engineered
evs
so in doing so what we
what we aimed to do was well we wanted
to deliver
the crispr cas9 complex transiently so
if you were to deliver it by
lentiviral transduction um which a lot
of laboratories
do do uh you would the lentivirus would
bind to a target cell the endocytose and
release its contents um so the
viral rna genome would be reverse
transcribed into
dna and integrated into the host genome
and then uh you would express your cas9
protein and guide rna and then you would
get
genomic dna cleavage however
again long-term expression of cast iron
is not really desirable
and we don't want to leave it in the
cell for a long time so
if you look to the right it's schematic
and you look at transient delivery by
evs you can still utilize the receptor
binding and endocytosis
and release of the contents but when
when the contents are released they're
already in its rnp format so it can
immediately
cleave the genomic dna target of
interest and after that the proteins
degraded so
hopefully you can get high activity of
on target cleavage
but the rnp complex would be degraded so
you reduce the risk of
off target cleavage by cas9
so to develop this system i'll save you
the trouble of looking at negative data
and i'll go into the system that
actually
worked for us in the end we decided to
utilize a chemical ligand-induced
dimerization system
um to package cas9 into our particles so
if you imagine
this is a producer cell so we're
producing
our um evs by
utilizing an hiv gag protein
which is fused to a dimerization domain
so gag localizes to the plasma membrane
and i'm only showing one gag molecule
here but up to 5000 gag molecules can be
incorporated into one particle
so what we what we did was we introduced
a
cell permeable chemical ligand into the
cell
which would bind to the dimerization
domain of gag and
at the same time uh cas9 is expressed
and also fused with the dimerization
domain
and this dimerizer will recruit cast
into the budding particle for release
so in doing this we we could
specifically package the cas9 protein
so when we produced these evs containing
cas9 protein we delivered them onto a
gfp reporter cell line that already
expressed guide rna
and if cas9 is delivered what happens is
that
this target sequence is cleaved and gfp
expression
is restored so if you get higher gfp
expression that means that caslin
was delivered into the cell and you
obtain genome editing
so you can see here on the figure on the
right bottom right
is that with the chemical ligand
introduced
you have a much higher degree of gfp
positive cells
as opposed to no chemical ligand during
the formation of these evs
so this indicates that cas9 can be
stochastically introduced into these
particles by overexpression but
specific incorporation using the
chemical again really enhanced the
packaging
of this cas9 protein so
the next part of the study for the
development of
our evs was packaging of the guide rna
so we really struggled with this and we
tried a lot of different
published approaches that that didn't
work for us so
what we ended up using at the end was
a system where we would have the guide
rna flanked by self-cleaving ribozymes
indicated on the top with the the dna
vector
and this is preceded by a side packaging
signal so what happens is that the dna
is
in the producer cell is transcribed into
rna
and the side packaging signal is um
it it binds to the gap protein so
in the budding vesicle so similarly like
you have
cas9 recruitment through dimerization
but gag is also recruiting
this rna molecule into the particle and
once the
rna molecule is recruited
the ribozymes self-cleave and then the
guide rna is liberated
in this all-in-one ev so if you look
at the bar graph on the right
what we did was we did incorporate
guide rna into these evs either using
the packaging signal or not using the
packaging signal
and you can see again some of the guide
rna can be packaged non-specifically
into the particle just by over
expression but if you can specifically
add the rna into the budding particle
using that
side packaging signal you can
dramatically increase the amount of
of guide rna package up to over
threefold
so this system that we developed we term
nanomedic for
membrane-derived extracellular vesicles
for the delivery of macromolecular cargo
so the advantages of this system is that
it's protein-based and transient
with no dna intermediate and again we
the key features of this system
are that we can incorporate cast 9 by
chemical ligand induced dimerization
and we can specifically enrich the guide
rna content by adding
a packaging signal so this um
nanometer particle on on the right
figure you can see that it so it has the
envelope for cell targeting
um gag serves as the beacon for
recruitment of both cas9 protein
and and the guide rna and um you have
your
kind of minimalist protein delivery
vehicle
for for delivery
so how do you make nanomedic nanomedic
is produced by
transfecting plasmids expressing
different
components of the nanomedic system so
you transfect them
into heck 293 t cells in the beginning
we were using adherent hec293t
cells and a lipid transfection reagent
and after 36 to 48 hours you would get
secretion of these nanometric particles
into the media
and all you do is you harvest the media
and concentrate it and now you have your
nanometric particles that you can
inoculate or just simply add
to um to cells so
the image on the top right is electron
microscopy image of our nanometer
particles
and we found that the diameter range
from about 130 to 160
nanometers in size
so just to go into some applications of
nanomedic
in various cell types in vitro and also
in vivo application we tried
delivering nanomedic onto t cells so
these are actually jerk cat cells
um geocapitals are not easily
transfected by lipid reagents
we wanted to target ccr5
which is exon1 of ccr5 which
is the co-receptor for hiv-1 entry
and what you can see on in the left
figure is that we added increasing
amounts of nanomedic to these t
cells and as you increase the amount of
nanomedic
you get increased dna cleavage indicated
by
these these two cleavage bands on the
bottom
and on the right side is just a bar
graph depiction
of the um the cleavage activity or the
indel's introduced and you can see there
is a dose-dependent
uh increase in mutation frequency as you
increase the amount of nanomedic added
to these cells
or over 50 percent so this is one
example of delivering to t
cells we also looked at uh delivery of
nanomedic into ips cell derived cortical
neurons
so in this example we are targeting
semihd1 which is a gene involved in
icardi guterre syndrome and autoimmune
disease
and we use two guide rnas to target exon
one
so these cortical neurons were
differentiated from ips cells
by neurogenin2 overexpression which is a
pretty efficient way to
uh induce uh cortical neuron
um from from ipscs so
in the right you can see this is a again
a t7e1 assay and
the bottom bands that appear in the
the blot image are um cleavage products
indicating
uh indels have been introduced at the
target site and you can see
both guide rnas had about 36 percent
um mutation frequency induced in these
cells
so nanomedic got in well to these
cortical neurons as well
uh one of the more important aspects of
our system is is the safety which
i was mentioning earlier in the
presentation so we used nanomedic to
target
um a site v gfa in heck 293 t
cells and the guide rna we chose was
a has been a reported promiscuous guide
rna which which has
unknown off target activity um so
the on target sequence is indicated in
green here
and off target is in red so you can see
there are only two base pairs mismatched
and these are
kind of distal base pairs from the pam
sequence so
when you deliver cast 9
and guide rna pipe in plasmid form you
can see on the bottom left
figure the on target cleavage of the
intended site is about 30 but the off
target cleavage indicated in
in red here is uh pretty high to over 15
and however when you look at nanomedic
delivery
the on target cleavage is just as good
as the plasmid delivery
sorry this is in heck 293 t cells but
the off target cleavage is virtually
eliminated so
that's this data indicates that you're
getting
um specific on target cleavage but
reducing the off target non-specific
cleavage
and the on to off ratio is over 60 fold
indicating that
you are getting high specificity when
you deliver a cas9 in
in the protein form so
with that we're pretty confident that
these particles are active and
comparable to
um dna delivery of the cas9
um and guide rna
and so we we then looked at nanomedic
inducing in high editing efficiency in
dmd patient ipscs so we looked at
two different dmd patient ips cell lines
either with an exon 44 deleted
or exon 46-47 deleted so
with the strategy for for dmd patient
cells you can induce
the exon skipping of exon 45 by either
targeting the splicing acceptor
or splicing donor site of exon 45 and
that would restore the open reading
frame
of the dystrophin protein expression
so when when you look at this the the
top left
figure shows just the splicing acceptor
site and the mutation frequency at the
splicing acceptor site
if you're adding nanomedic to target the
slicing acceptor site
either by itself or in combination with
a splicing
donor nano medic you can see that
you get high indel frequency induced
over
60 percent and is pretty similar in both
dmd patient lines
and also in a healthy donor line
similarly with the splicing donor site
targeted you can get
um high efficiency over 50 percent
targeting uh the splicing donor of exon
45
alone or even if you combine it with a
splicing acceptor site um you're still
getting high
indel induction and again for the
patient cells both patient cells and
also for the healthy donor
so the bottom right the bottom left
figure
shows the um pcr amplification of the
genomic dna
region of interest so if exon 45 is
removed by simultane
simultaneous targeting of the splicing
acceptor and slicing donor site
you should see a smaller pcr product
so that's indeed what you see when you
add
the splicing acceptor and splicing donor
nanomedic so
we saw up to 36 percent of the genomic
dna deletion of exon 45 in two patient
cells
and also in a healthy donor cell and the
bottom right
figure shows kind of the bar graph
showing um
a summary of the the exon 45 deletion
from these three cell lines so it's it's
pretty consistent across
three different ips cell lines so once
we obtained these edited cells
we differentiated them to skeletal
muscle cells and looked at
dystrophin expression so
this is uh on the left side you can see
rt pcr of um cdna extracted from the
skeletal muscle cells
the bottom left shows kind of a bar
graph showing the exon 45
skipping efficiency so
basically if you target the splicing
acceptor site alone
the exon skipping efficiency is only
about 30 percent
targeting a splicing donor site had
really little effect on the exxon
skipping
and however if you targeted both the
acceptor and donor sites you can see
that there was a synergistic effect
where you have
over 90 exon skipping and
if you look on the right and you see the
western blot analysis
you you see protein expression of
dystrophin
restored in these cells um with highly
efficient exon skipping
when using a combination of the splicing
acceptor and splicing donor nanomedic
so i think this data shows that you can
highly effective
edit um ips cells
and that when differentiated to the cell
type of interest they show the
expected phenotype
so then we looked at um
in vivo delivery of nanomedic using a
luciferase reporter mouse so in the top
left
schematic you can see that this reporter
mouse
has luciferase knocked into the
rosalocus however
the lucifer's gene is interrupted
actually by exon 45 of human dystrophin
so if you can induce the skipping of
this
exon by adding the splicing acceptor and
splicing donor nanomedic
similarly to what we did in the ips
cells you can restore lucifer's
expression so if you get luciferase
expression that means that exon skipping
has occurred
so if you look at the bottom left we
injected by uh into the grass
gastrosemis
muscle um nanomedic for the splicing
acceptor and splicing donor sites and we
did this in five mice
and looking at the kinetics of lucifer's
expression you can see that
lucifer's expression happens pretty
early on within a few days
and it kind of plateaus so it plateaus
and it's sustained for
160 days and these results indicate that
you have permanent disruption
of the splicing acceptor and slicing
donor site of
human district and exon 45 in this
reporter system
so when we sacrificed the mice after 189
days and looked at the rt pcr
we could see that um exon skipping
occurred at about a seven percent
in um from samples taken from three mice
that's indicated in the top right figure
and if we looked at
the genomic percentage of genomic
deletion in the bottom right
um by deep sequencing we also confirmed
that there were deletions in
up to six to seven percent of um
the genomic dna analyzed so the the
deletion pattern
was mostly below 50 base pairs in
deletion but we did have some
larger dna deletion of about 130 base
pairs
kind of indicating that both uh that
that exon
45 was removed from this reporter system
so with that we were able to show
um not only in vitro delivery but we're
also able to show
in vivo delivery into this reporter
mouse
so we we tested various cell lines um
and we found efficient delivery in in
all of the cell lines indicated
we also tested um multiple endogenous
loci and found efficient editing
so once we established that nanomedic
worked
we went we wanted to develop
a culture system uh that was suspension
based for more scalable production of
nanomedic
and i'll go into the development of how
how we did that using electroporation
so our
previous system used adherent cells
adherent 293 t
cells we also use fetal bovine serum
for the media and a lipid transfection
reagent
the problem i had when i was trying to
scale up the
nanomedic production the sedharensa line
is that the adherent cells
they came off the plates really easily
it was hard to get even
seating density when i went to larger
plates uh we wanted to remove the fetal
bovine serum to make it xeno-free to
make it applicable for
for more potentially uh clinical
application later on
and the the lipid transfection reagent
um
there wasn't much room for optimization
of delivery of your dna using this
so we um we found that
just technically it was difficult using
this adherent system
so switching to a suspension
hex system available from thermo fissure
that can be grown at high cell density
we
also switched to a completely different
um
chemically defined xenofree media which
could be
gmp compatible and we also wanted to
move away from
lipid transfection to electroporation
using the mac site platform which is um
shown in in the bottom right machine so
we we wanted to hopefully achieve
scalable
um production of nanomedic which
was easier technically to handle and was
also applicable for for clinical
application so
i mean uh the pictures on the bottom
show okay if i was generating an
inherent
um anonymity from adhering cells i'd
have a lot of plates
like indicated in the bottom left uh the
shaker flask i could
minimize the the space taken the tissue
culture hood and
and also reduce the handling of these
cells so that's what we were aiming for
in the beginning
and just the electroporation protocol we
used was
we expanded our hex cells and and
patches
passage them the day before
electroporation on the day of
electroporation we exchanged in mac site
buffer which is just a salt solution and
a universal buffer from
for all cell types we then mix the cells
with
our plasmid dna for for nanomedic
added them to the cuvette and
electroporated
after electroporation we rested the
cells for 30 to 40 minutes at 37 degrees
to allow for
membrane recovery and then we culture
the cells as normal for 36 to 48 hours
and harvested the nanomedic particles we
would then
inoculate them on reporter cells and
check the flow
the gfp expression by flow cytometry
the the initial experiment we did
however was um we checked
gfp dna plasmid expression and we wanted
to compare if electroporation was better
than lipid transfection
uh in the suspension cells so what you
can see
here is just gfp expression um this is a
histogram plot
using two different max site energies so
it's a heck protocol and optimization
for protocol these are
two somewhat lower energy protocols
available on the electroporation
platform
and we compare that with the lipid
transfection
reagent that came with the lv max cells
so what you can see is with the the max
8 system you can get nearly 100 percent
of the cells expressing gfp and the main
fluorescence intensity was
was shifted um far to the right and i
mean these cells were really green after
48 hours
visually by eye with the lipid
transfection region you can also get
high efficiency of gfb plasmid delivery
however the the expression intensity was
was a lot lower than electroporation
and not only that if you look at the
viability the viability of the cells was
around 80 after 48 hours with
electroporation
versus 40 with the lipid transfection
region so
we found better delivery efficiency and
higher viability
um using the maxsite platform
so next just to kind of um
to summarize the the process again we
electroporate our
nanometic plasmids um into
the suspension hexels by the maxi
instrument
um we would harvest our nanometer
particles and then
inoculate them onto reporter cells and
then if we get gfp expression
that indicates that nanomedic was
efficiently delivered into the reporter
cells and
active so this
slide shows the optimization of the
energy used
for um electroporating the producer cell
to generate nanomedic
uh and so what happened was if you go
from low energy indicated by 4
to the highest energy indicated by 10
here
increasing the energy increased the
amount of functional
nonometic particles from the producer
cells which
is indicated by the gfp expression
and the reporter cells so the higher
energy
the more nanomedic produced from from
these cells
energy 9 and 10 had comparable output of
nanomedic
but the cell viability was a bit better
in nine
uh one one kind of challenge we
encountered when we were
optimizing was that um
production of of uh
resulted in a lower cell number and
lower cell viability
um after 36 hours and so
one way we were able to kind of resolve
this issue was to add
dna so we would electroporate the cells
and after electroporating the cell the
dna is introduced in the cell
um but any remaining dna would be
degraded by
adding benzenes uh so we added benzenes
and um to cells electrocuted at two
energies either energy four or energy
nine
and what you can see is there you get a
recovery
um of cell survival when you add
benzenes
at both energies so there are less cells
at energy
9 but compared without benzenes you do
increase the cell number
at 36 hours post electroporation
and this is just showing the producer
cells remaining
at the time of harvest of nanomedic you
can see that there are only six million
cells remaining if you don't add
benzenes to the electrocreated cells
and you have over three times more cells
when you add benzenes
so what happens to the nanomedic
produced from
from the cells when you add benzene so
the cell
number and viability increased if you
had benzenes and actually so does the
amount of nanomedic produce so if you
add benzenes at energy four
energy nine you get higher yields of
nanomedic being produced from these
producer cells
as indicated by the gfp expression from
the reporter system
so we could increase the amount of
nanomedic by by increasing producer cell
survival
the other thing we found was by
decreasing the amount of
vsvg plasmid which is the surface
envelope used on nanomedic for cell
targeting
we could also increase the um
production of nanomedic and its delivery
into recipient cells
we didn't really look deep into the
mechanism but we believe by reducing
the vsvg amount you're reducing the
amount of
empty particles which might be
um coated with vsvg protein
that might compete with um with
with all in one kind of nanomedic for
delivery so
uh we we got more efficient uh
production
and delivery of nanomedic when we reduce
the amount of vsvg
so after optimizing conditions for
nanomedic
we we then look to produce nanomedic by
flow electroporation
so here you see kind of a range of max
sites
um cuvettes uh from from the left to
right
from the left is the smallest volume you
can work
you know as low as 15 microliters and to
the right you see with the cl2 you can
go as high as 100 mls for
electroporation
we were actually working for the
optimization that um the oc 400 range to
400 microliters of cells in dna
and we were using approximately 60
million cells for electroporation
so after identifying the dna
concentration
and the electroporation energy uh
we could then apply those same
conditions
for the cl2 um so flow electrocution
works by
the cells being in a sample bag and
flowing
three mls at a time into an
electroporation chamber
and and then um sent to a collection bag
so just to give you an example of how
flow electroporation
looks in terms of consistency and
scalability
um if you have 100 mls and this is
looking at k562
cells transfected with gfp plasmid dna
so each 3ml fraction that was
electroporated was
collected and then analyzed for gfp
expression viability
and you can see 30 separate fractions
that were electroporated
had very similar gfp expression
and cell viability and when you compare
that to
um the small scale electroporation with
40 million cells
you can see that the expression
viability were also similar so
going from 40 million cells to 6 billion
cells with the
cl2 gave very consistent and
reproducible results
so in terms of our system how
the how we worked the um the flow of the
experiment was
we um scaled up production of
our um suspension hex cells
in large erlenmeyer flasks and then
we performed flow electroporation of 1.2
billion cells we treated with benzenes
because we found that it helped survive
all the producer cells and then
we we cultured the cells for 36 to 48
hours
in the presence of a dimerization ligand
and then we harvested
nanomedic and we analyzed the amount of
cas9 being incorporated
so in this um
slide what you can see is we compared
production of nanomedic
using 48 10 centimeter plates
um compared with suspension
culture so each one yielded 480 mls of
of culture and what we did was we
we concentrated nanomedic and then we we
lysed the particles
and performed an in vitro assay to
quantify the amount of
active rnp being released
from these cells using both systems and
um
once the rnp is released in in vitro
we add a pcr dna template
which would be cleaved in the presence
of active
cas9 rnp so you should see two cleavage
bands so
on the right here you see a standard
recombinant casino
protein and if you increase the amount
of cas9 protein you increase the amount
of cleavage bends
so we would just compare the amount of
cas9 contained in these
nanometer particles with the standard
curve to quantify the amount of
of cas9 being released
and what we found was that
the adherent system with 480mls release
roughly 27 nanograms per ml of
active rnp complex if we compare that
with kind of a small scale run with 60
million cells and with 1.9 billion cells
there was a reduction of about 34
percent
of the active cas9 being released
however
we see consistency between the small
scale and large scale runs
um for nanomedic production and
considering that we
changed the cell type and we also
changed the media composition completely
and the delivery method um we felt that
the suspension was
easier and more manageable if we wanted
to scale up further
and not only that we were able to um
obtain xeno-free conditions using a
chemically defined media
meaning that there could be potential
clinical application
for the system so
in summary we developed a xeno-free
nanomedic production system by
electroporation
that could be scalable from 60 million
cells to 1.2 billion cells
we found that it technically there it
was easier to handle
and we feel there's promise for
industrial applications
benzene's treatment we found after
electroporation
did enhance cell viability and we were
able to improve nanometric yields
so the energy used for electroporation
if you increase the energy you increase
the amount of nanometer particles
produced
and we did feel at the end that
electroporation was an efficient method
for producing nanomedic
future directions of this project we we
think that the cell targeting can be
changed of nanomedic by changing the
the viral envelope or or maybe adding a
single chain antibody um
the other thing too is that you're not
limited to just cast 9 delivery
you can incorporate any protein of
interest by
fusing a dimerization domain to it i
didn't show it in this presentation but
we were able to efficiently package
luciferous protein
as well into nanomedic and we could
deliver that in in vivo
as well um one could add
a viral antigen and potentially use
nanomedic for vaccine production
um there are certain aspects of the
downstream optimization which are
further needed such as
affinity chromatography purification
which would
increase the purity of nanomedic and and
maybe allow for more efficient delivery
so there are a lot of acknowledgements a
lot of people contributed to this study
uh akitsuholta who was my mentor
and who really helped to um give ideas
for the project
i i'd like to thank him as well as
noriko sasukawa
mandi lang and yuya okazaki who
really helped push the revision of the
experiments i had a lot of help from
summer interns who motivated me to work
harder and and i really appreciate their
support
as well as a collaboration with takeda
and for the t cyber project yukimasa
makita and hiroyuki
hozumi and naoto inukai were responsible
for the in vivo studies
uh june komano gave a lot of ideas for
when i first started the nano medic
production
and um i and other researchers like
takeshi nota who helped with electron
microscopy and yuko fujita
so um with that i'd like to thank you
and i and i'm welcome to take any
questions or comments
um on the right i also want to point out
that we have a research spotlight on
this study
that is downloadable from from a link
that you can find
um and there's a link to the
manuscript itself so again thank you for
your time and
i'm i welcome any questions or comments
thank you
great thank you peter for that
informative presentation
so at this time we will open it up and
use the remaining portion of the session
to ask peter any questions the viewers
might have so if you have a question
you'd like to ask it please do so now
just as a reminder you can use the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen so
let's go ahead and get started so first
question that has come in peter is how
does the neto medic
transient protein delivery system
compare with other systems that are
currently available
well i mean if you compare the the
nanomedic system
with other transient systems i i did try
other published reports like um
of uh the nanoblade system where you
would fuse
cast nine with gag but there are a lot
of limitations of that system because um
you you have to cleave cast nine
uh using a a gag protease to liberate
the protein and that sometimes cuts cas9
itself so
i think with the other systems i i i
didn't find that the guide rna packaging
too was
efficient so at least with other
published reports it
i i was able um i wasn't able to find
both being incorporating the particles
efficiently okay great
um next question how does neto medic
compare with aav delivery
um i think it's it's kind of difficult
to compare both
uh nanomedics a protein-based delivery
system and
an aev just needs a single dna vector to
express a large amount
of cas9 we did some preliminary studies
where we found the kinetics at least of
nanomedic
were faster but but overall i i don't
think we
we fully optimized the um
the conditions for kind of a fair
comparison so
yeah i it's it's if we need to
develop it further okay great
next question is are the tropisms
similar to lentiviral vsvg
and do you need to use immune suppressor
for in vivo use
the tropism is exactly the same because
this particle uses vspg
for delivery total target low density
lipoprotein receptor
in terms of uh immune suppressor for
in vivo use i i unless
the the patient has been exposed to
vesicular stomatitis virus or maybe
hiv beforehand i i don't think there
would have to be an immune suppressor
okay um what about comparing with just
electroporation the ribonucleot
the rival and nucleoprotein particle and
that is cas9 protein complex in solution
with uh genomic rna
oh with guide ernie so oh we we did we
just
do this it's um one figure in our paper
but what we found was
for example if you if you elect to break
the rnp in
in solution you have to you have to add
a lot
more um so we compared like 10
micrograms of rnp
being electrocuted versus 200 nanograms
being delivered by
our nanomedic and we have actually
higher delivery of
rnp into ips cells with our system so we
we found that it's
either the same or or it's been better
in some cases
than electroporation okay
um next question can nanomedic be
administered in vivo by
intravenous injection
uh we did do some preliminary studies
with that um
trying to deliver lucifer's protein
intravenously we couldn't observe
luciferous signal intravenously so
for now at least it's just through
localized injection
but we we will optimize in the future
probably for for more
systemic delivery okay
what is the cell target specificity of
the nanomedic system
so kind of related to an earlier
question so we use
vspg which targets low density
lipoprotein receptor which is expressed
on
on virtually all cell types uh so there
isn't a specific
uh cell type that that we're trying to
target right now
um in in the future you could treat you
could change the the viral envelope or
or maybe add
an antibody to target a specific cell so
that that's something that could be
engineered later for
more spell cell specificity
okay great um next question what other
types of cargo could be loaded into
nanometer
um so i mean that's a really interesting
question we did load
cast nine and and um ideally you could
load other genome editing tools or
perhaps something like prime editor
which is actually quite large to add by
dna plasmid
so in terms of gene editing you can add
a variety of nucleuses or other editors
you could probably add fluorescent
proteins for for
labeling cells at least transiently and
uh
also for for vaccine development you
could load them with viral antigen
which could be an option too okay
uh next question would it be possible to
load a dna donor template into nanomedic
for homologous
directed repair with crisco cassini
uh i don't think it would be possible to
load
the donor template inside the nanomedic
particle
a similar system called nanoblades
was able to to kind of complex the donor
template outside of the particle by
by adding uh poly brain and then they
could co-deliver it together
so we did try a similar approach which
wasn't in the study and we were able to
get up to nine percent
hdr efficiency in ipf cells by by
pre-complexing
nanomedic with with a donor template so
it is possible it's just
i don't think you can package the donor
template inside nanomedic you'd have to
be externally kind of
um packaged yeah okay uh
are there other applications in addition
to crispr cas9 genome editing
uh other applications the genome editing
right so
so kind of similar to what i said before
for for maybe
labeling the cells or vaccine
development
i guess for any kind of molecule you
want to deliver
maybe you can even deliver the crave
recombinase
um so i mean any any
protein of interest can be loaded into
nanomedic
i think it's more advantageous to try to
load larger protein cargo that you
wouldn't
normally be able to deliver by by dna
plasmids
okay next is how long did the electric
pouration optimization for nanomedic
production take
um this one it wasn't
too low i think i was pretty able to
optimize at the small scale on the oc
400 within
two months the only limitation i really
had was was i didn't have too much
uh incubator space where with enough
shakers to do more at one time
but i i was able to optimize and scale
up within i would say
two months up to the cl2 so it was
pretty fast for the optimization
great um looks like next question what
are some other technical challenges in
producing nanomedic
i guess the technical challenges i found
were were the purity of the particles
because
when you concentrate them it's not just
nanomedic but your
your concentrating exosomes or or
potentially some other cell debris so i
i think purification by
affinity chromatography would be pretty
important to remove
any cellular debris or exosomes from the
nanomedic
preparation and also maybe any residual
dna that might be left over
so and also i guess for nanometer
another technical issue could be what
the more you scale up um it was just
more of a
of the culture conditions for a large
cell number which which we didn't
have the capacity for in an academic lab
at the time so
maybe those kind of technical issues
came up
during the optimization
makes sense okay next uh and looks like
final question
is there a risk of other cellular
components being accidentally
incorporated inside of an animatic
particle during production which
potentially may affect the target cell
so we did we did do a proteomics
analysis of the nanometic
particles we we did find some kind of
cellular host proteins but considering
that their
their proteins being incorporated i
think the delivery of those proteins
would be pretty
transient and not in the high
concentrations i
i don't um i don't imagine that there
would be any kind of
toxic issues with that
okay um actually another question did
come in have you looked at the content
of the nanomedic and it's yes
what were the what were were there other
proteins sorry peter
oh sorry so i i guess similar to the to
the last question
but in particular what kind of proteins
i i guess a lot of exosome markers
were in there of course our animated
components like yad were
were highly incorporated um
but i i don't think there was anything
overwhelmingly like
incorporated more than the
over-expressed proteins we have in there
okay uh well that looks like all the
questions that we had come in so thank
you very much for
um you know for answering those peter i
wanted this point to remind
our audience that the recorded version
of today's talk will be made available
soon after this live session and you
will be notified
via email when it becomes available also
any questions that are unable to be
answered today which i think we got to
all of them um but those that do come in
during the on-demand session
will be answered using the email address
you provided during the time of
registration
so before we go i wanted to take a
little bit of time to thank peter for
his detailed presentation
to thank our customers and industry
partners for allowing us to share their
important work with a larger
uh community and to thank lab roots for
their supportive webinar team for
organizing and promoting our event
and lastly i would like to thank you our
audience participants for joining us
today
and for their interesting questions so
this concludes our session for today
until next time take care